Speaker 1: Mississippi's governor, Tate Reeves,
says that there's a reason that in Mississippi,
people are just kind of going about their business
normally, maybe not getting vaccinated as much,
etc.. And the reason is that because in
Mississippi, more people are religious,
meaning they believe in an afterlife, they
believe in eternal life. They believe in heaven.
They are less scared of the virus. This is
Governor Tate Reeves. Let's look at the article
from Business Insider. Mississippi Governor Tate
Reeves in remarks Saturday said that people in
the state were less scared of covid because
they believe in eternal life as new infections
reach record levels and hospitalizations spike.
Now, remember, Mississippi is highly infected
and under-resourced. When you look
at health care, quality and access,
Mississippi is usually fiftieth out of
fifty states, sometimes forty ninth.
They're in and engaged in a battle for the
to the race to the bottom with Alabama.
When it comes to health care, it's a disaster in
Mississippi. And the governor is saying, well,
we believe in an eternal life, so we're not that
scared. Reeves made the remarks to a gathering of
state Republicans at a. Fundraiser on Thursday.
Quote, I'm often asked by some of my friends on
the other side of the aisle about covid and
why does it seem like folks in Mississippi and
maybe in the mid-South are a little less scared,
shall we say, when you believe in eternal life,
when you believe that living on this earth is but
a blip on the screen, then you don't have to be so
scared of things. Reeves went on to say. God
also tells us to take necessary precautions,
and we all have opportunities and abilities to
do that, and we should all do that. I encourage
everyone to do so. Mississippi has recorded
more new covid cases per capita than any state
around 127 per 100000, according to an analysis
by The New York Times. The wave of infections
in Mississippi has put state health services at
a breaking point, with 93 percent of ICU beds
in use. Sixty three percent of those occupied
by covid patients, according to HHS data. Now,
you know, the thing about these kind of claims,
we're less scared because this earthly life is
is only a blip in terms of the total life. This
would sort of apply to everything like seatbelts,
taking antibiotics when you have a sinus infection
or strep throat. And yet most of these people do
these things. There are some like I know Christian
Science is very much skeptical of medication and
sort of traditional treatment, et cetera, but
this applies to a lot of different things that
most of them do. But if you're really going to
take this approach, you should really take it
fully. Don't take the mealymouthed approach. Don't
go to the hospital when you get sick. Right. Go to
church and pray or even don't do anything because
you're going to more quickly get to that eternal
afterlife if you die from whatever is afflicting
you. There's also another, more sensible approach,
which I think I've seen some religious left
wingers take, which is God made the vaccine
possible. I'm going to go and get the frickin
vaccine right. When God answers prayers,
God may be answering the prayers by giving us a
vaccine or giving us masks or giving us ways to
attend church safely in our cars or whatever the
case may be. It it almost starts to take on. Like
if you really take this to its full conclusion,
it starts to take on kind of this rapture porn
ideology of the sooner I die, the sooner I get to
heaven. And some of these rapture belief systems
take that on. They say it's going to be so great.
It's good. I hope that the rapture comes and we
all are, you know, that there's fire and fury and
whatever else they believe. Brimstone, what are
the terms they use? I don't remember because I'm
going to get to heaven sooner. And I read a tweet
from a religious person who said, I believe
in eternal life. That's my religious belief.
But I believe in taking precautions to avoid
covid because I'm in no rush to exit this life.
I don't know if in the afterlife I can
be with my kids. I just don't know what
that's going to be like. I believe in
it, but I don't know what it's going to
be. So you know what? I'm going to get the
vaccine and I'm going to try to stay safe.
It's a completely delusional perspective from Tate
Reeves, but it's also being applied hypocritically
because a lot of these people, they were seatbelts
and they take antibiotics and they wear a helmet
when they ride their motorcycle, whatever the
case may be. But yet on this one, they're saying
there's no reason to be scared of this because we
believe in an afterlife. It's really scary stuff.
And unfortunately, it is not an uncommon
set of beliefs in the United States